Welcome to 3ABN today Bible Q&A. This is
a special time for me because I love
asking questions.
My my responsibility is very very
simple. We have 12 questions and it's my
responsibility to present them to these
three of my special friends and my
precious wife. We have James Rafferty,
we have Johnny Denzy, we have Shelley
Quinn. And so once again, I just want to
thank you for being here with us. And uh
just know that uh
I hope as you watch these, it'll bring a
question to your mind and then you'll
want to send it into us. The way you get
it to us is uh if you're going to text
it, it's 6182283975.
If you want to email it, it's bible
qa3abn.tv.
TV and if you want to Instagram 3ABN
official.
Does anybody have any special questions?
I want to ask a special question to each
one of you before we start. You study
this. What do you get out of it, James?
Well, one of the things that came to
light as I was studying this was how
important it is for us to read the Bible
and take out what it says rather than
putting in what we want it to say.
>> Amen.
>> Johnny, what uh what do you get out of
whenever you're studying this studying
for one of these topics? How does your
mind work and what do you get out of
this?
>> Well, you know, it it really draws us to
close to Christ is my understanding. you
you as you're searching for answers to
these questions and you ask the Lord for
help, it draws me closer to the Lord.
And it seems as uh as the Lord opens
your understanding to understand things
you didn't understand before
>> and it's a learning process, I think
every single time it's a learning
process and trusting in the Lord.
>> Amen. Shelly,
>> even if I think I know the answer, I'm
going to go to scripture and review what
I believe and make sure that it is
scripturally supported. And I think I do
that with every sermon. It doesn't
matter if it's if it's something I feel
well verssed in, I'm going to study it
again because that gives me an assurance
of the truth.
>> Amen.
Well, we have 12 questions. There's a
couple of questions that are long
questions. So, we're going to get right
with it. But I want to have a prayer
before we start. Father, as we come
together,
we just ask to be empty of self. Father,
this is a good time whenever we can get
into the word and hear what the Bible
says. Thank you for the gift that you've
given each one of my co-workers here and
that they have spent time and and
digging deeper and Father, they're going
to share what they've learned in a short
time. So, Father, be with us, take care
of us, fill us with the Holy Spirit. And
Father, may this whole uh program be
inspired by the Holy Spirit, and we'll
all be blessed. And we ask this in the
name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. James, let's start with you. It's
a long question. In Genesis 46, we see
the 12 sons of Jacob listed, including
Dan. In Genesis 48:5,
Jacob adopts Joseph's sons, Ephraim and
M uh Manasseh, as his own, just as
Reuben and Simeon are his own. In
Revelation 7, the 12 tribes of the
144,000 representing the saved are
listed, and both Dan and Ephraim are
missing. Why is Dan excluded? And why
was he replaced by Manasseh? I
understand Ephraim's exclusion being
born and raised in Egypt, but what about
Dan? And this is from Nola and Marilyn.
Wow.
>> Well, Nicole, this is one of those times
in the Bible that leads to some amazing
spiritual insights and some practical
truth. I think that's really going to be
important for us today. So, we can begin
in Genesis 49. You mentioned Genesis 46.
Genesis 49 is also a repeat of the 12
tribes of Israel, the 12 sons of Jacob.
But this time the characteristics of
those sons is mentioned. And that's
really important because when you look
in Genesis 49 16 and 17, you see the
characteristics of Dan. Dan is described
there as an adder in the path, a serpent
in the way that bites the heels, the
horse's heels, so the rider falls
backwards. Uh the word Dan actually
means to judge. The word Danielle means
God is judge. So what we see here is a
powerful character lesson because Dan is
missing from the list of those who are
sealed with the with the character of
God in their foreheads in Revelation
chapter 7 as you mentioned the saved.
And so what God is telling us is that
people who are backbiting, people who
are serpent-like, people who are
judgmental of others cannot receive the
seal of God. This is the this is the the
uh lesson that God is bringing to us.
The practical lesson. You know, many
times we argue about the number of the
144,000. Is it literal? Is it symbolic?
What does it mean? It'd be better for us
to understand this lesson because with
Dan excluded, that leaves 11 tribes. And
like you said, there's one tribe that's
added, and it's not Ephraim, who is
joined to his idols. According to Hosea,
it is Manasseh. Now, according to
Genesis 41:51,
Manasseh was Joseph's firstborn son. And
Joseph called his firstborn Manasseh
because he said, "God has caused me to
forget all of my trouble and all that
happened in my father's house." Well,
what was his trouble? What happened in
his father's house? Well, unfortunately,
Joseph's brothers were envious and
jealous of Joseph because he was
especially loved of the father. And so
they sold him into slavery in Egypt. And
even though he was sold into slavery in
Egypt, Joseph, God overruled his life
and Joseph became second in command in
Egypt. And eventually, as Joseph puts it
in his own words, God led him there to
save their lives. Long story short,
Joseph called Manasseh his firstborn
because that word means to forget or to
forgive. That's the implications of the
word. Joseph had forgiven his brothers
for the terrible thing that he did to
them. Just like Jesus on the cross said,
"Father, forgive them. They know not
what they do." Just like Steven said,
"Lay not the sin of their charge." When
they were when he was being stoned to
death. Just so Joseph named his eldest
Manasseh. The lesson, God is going to
seal the saved with a with uh with his
seal, with his character if they replace
their bitterness and their
judgmentalness, their backbiting, with a
spirit of forgiveness and longsuffering
toward their brethren, even those
brethren who may mistreat them.
>> Amen. Amen. Good answer,
>> Johnny.
>> Your first question. Who are the sons of
man?
>> Uh, thank you for that question. And it
seems like to be an interesting question
because uh uh we have in the Bible the
phrase the sons of men uh the children
of men and it depends on the context. We
have to read the context in order to see
what is really talking about there. And
when you go into the book of Genesis you
see a a a a passage there or a story
there about people the the sons of God
saw that the daughters of men which
could be the sons of the sons of men as
well. daughters of men. And it seems
that people got confused as they read
this. They they think this is angels. So
in that particular passage in Genesis,
uh which is I think Genesis chapter 5, I
didn't write it down. Um it's making a
difference between those that serve God,
the sons of God, and those that are
wicked, uh which are the descendants of
Cain. Because when you look at Genesis
chapter uh four and you see the
genealogy of Cain, then it starts
talking about the sons of Seth and the
sons of Adam. Then you see that there's
a difference there. But let's go ahead
and go to Psalms 33 uh verse 13 and 14
to see how the Bible describes who the
sons of men are. It says uh Psalms
33:13, "The Lord looks from heaven. He
sees all the sons of men from the place
of his dwelling. He looks on all the
inhabitants of the earth. Generally when
you when it says the sons of men, it is
really talking in general about
humanity, men, women, and children. So
this is why verse 14, I'll read it
again. From the place of his dwelling,
he looks on all the inhabitants of the
earth. Uh now let's look at a verse in
Isaiah 52 verse 13 and 14. And look at
how this is phrased here. Behold my
servant shall deal prudently. He shall
be exalted and extolled and be very
high. This is a passage talking about
Jesus Christ as the suffering servant
which again is picked up again in Isaiah
53. So now I go to uh verse 14. It says
just as many were astonished at you, so
his visage was marred more than the more
than any man. So it calls this servant,
my servant. It calls him uh that he
shall deal prudent prudently and he will
be exalted very high. But it also says
his visage, that is the the the the
face and the look of Christ was going to
be marred more than any man. So again
generally when it says sons of men it's
talking in general about uh humanity men
and women and children
>> certainly makes
>> but since they didn't mention any any
particular scripture we have to give you
general idea.
>> Yes. Yes. Good answer. Shelley your
first question. I was wondering if you
could explain how to talk with an
atheist and share evidence that God is
real and that Jesus is his son. And this
is from TJ in Illinois.
>> TJ, this is an important question and it
begins by building a relationship.
In First Peter 3:15, we're advised,
always be ready to give a reason for the
hope that is in you, yet with gentleness
and respect. A loving approach is your
first key.
>> You are not, the goal is not to win an
argument. You're not trying to prove
someone wrong, but to reveal a God who
loves them. You know, often atheists
carry deep hurts within them. They've
got a lot of questions. And often if if
they are listening,
if we are showing Christ in our actions,
that speaks louder than our arguments. I
would say the second thing point I would
make is show them that God is a God of
love and fair justice. You know a common
objection is an idea many people have
become atheists because they've been
taught that God is going to burn the
wicked forever and ever and ever
throughout all the ages. And if they
understand
that there is a second death, that the
wicked are going to be consumed and
turned into ashes, and that God is just
and merciful, and we find that second
death four different times in
Revelation, uh particularly Revelation
2014 is the verse I noted. But if they
realize that it's a final and permanent,
it shows that God is his justice is
fair, not cruel. And then start with
common ground. You know, atheists
respect reason. They expect respect
science and morality. So point out the
beauty of the creation and the design in
creation which is to most thinking
people an evidence of a creator. You
know even scientists admit that the
universe had a beginning. So everything
that begins must have a cause something
that caused it to begin. For us God is
that cause. The evidence for Jesus. Oh,
there's a lot of evidence for Jesus.
History shows he was a real person. He
was crucified under Roman authority. And
even non-Christian
historians recorded his life. What makes
him different from other religious
leaders is his resurrection. And this
was an event that the disciples were
willing to die for. Now, if it were a
lie, why would they not just deny him
and save their lives? So, the fifth
thing I would say is that changed lives
are evidence. It's the greatest proof
that God exists when we see people's
lives transformed. The former atheist
Lee Stroel wrote a book, The Case for
Christ. He set out to prove that Christ
didn't exist and to prove the Bible
wrong. And guess what? As he studied
history, archaeology, biology,
everything, he learned that Christ is
real and God's word is true. There's a
documentary on Roku that you can even
watch called The Case for Christ. A lot
of good scientific evidence. And then as
Adventists, I think it's important to
emphasize prophecy. If we realize a good
example, Daniel fortold
the rise and fall of world empires
centuries in advance. And that's
evidence that God is real and his word
is trustworthy. And at the end of the
program, if we have a moment, I've got
some resources for you from Adventist
authors.
>> Amen. Thank you, Shelley. James, your
second question.
How will the world enforce a National
Sunday law? And this is from Noah.
Noah, that's a great question. You know,
we don't know exactly how this is going
to happen, but we do know that it's
going to take place through control of
the economy. This is what we read in
Revelation 13 15 to1 17. Let's just look
at those verses really quickly. It says
there in Revelation 13 15 to1 17. And he
had power to give life unto the image of
the beast that the image of the beast
should both speak and cause as many as
would not worship the image of the beast
should be killed. And he caused all
small, great, rich, poor, free bond to
receive a mark in their right hand or in
their foreheads that no man might buy or
sell save he that had the mark or the
name of the beast or the number of his
name. So here we see economic control is
the way that the mark of the beast or
the national Sunday law is going to be
enforced. Now we see the same thing in
the book of Daniel chapter 11 which is a
parallel passage to Revelation 13. It's
describing the same monetary control in
this way. Daniel 11 we'll start here in
verse 43. and he shall enter into the
glorious land, and many countries shall
be overthrown, but these shall escape
out of his hand, even Edom and Moab and
the chief of the children of Ammon. And
he shall stretch forth his hand also
upon the countries, and the land of
Egypt shall not escape, but he shall
have power over the treasures of gold
and silver and all the precious things
of Egypt, and the Libyans and the
Ethiopians shall be in his depths. So we
have in Daniel 11 a parallel to
Revelation 13. Revelation 13 says all
small, great, rich, poor, free, bond. In
Daniel 11, it talks about Egypt and the
glorious land and the Libyans and the
Ethiopians and Moab. So all of the
powers of the world, all the countries
of the world are going to be controlled
through the economy. Now, both of these
texts are speaking about the economic
power of worldwide control. And there
are two examples of this that we can
look at in our world today. I can share
with you first of all that when I
traveled to Pakistan in 1997 which is an
Islamic state. In other words, Islam is
Islamic uh religion rules there. That
when I woke up on Sunday, everything was
closed. All the businesses were closed.
Everything was shut down. Now Sunday is
not the day for worship in a Muslim
country. Friday is their day of prayer
when they go to the mosque to pray, not
Sunday. So I asked why was this and they
told me they said this is because the
world economy has pressured Pakistan to
be open for business on Friday because
everyone else is and closed for business
on Sunday because everyone else is. Even
though we're Islamic State, even though
the religious fundamentalists don't like
this, the economic pressure buying and
selling with keeping up with the rest of
the world forces us to do this. Now,
some years ago in the state of Oregon,
this is another example of why secular
people or non-Christian people would
actually go along with this economic
enforcement of Sunday laws. There was a
secular business dealer, car business
dealer, who um got together at a
downtime economically and wrote a letter
to the legislature with all the other
car dealerships and asked them to
enforce blue laws, blue Sunday laws
because they said they needed the
economic benefits that would come from
closing their businesses on Sunday. And
if it was enforced, so everyone had to
do it, then they could have less
overhead for running their business,
being closed an extra day, and they
could actually hire higherend employees,
car salesmen, because car salesmen that
uh usually have Sundays off are family
people and people that go to church and
they're they're they've got a better
reputation maybe than others. So these
are two examples of how many people,
even in nations that are not Christians,
will go along with Sunday laws. Now, I
just want to emphasize something here.
In Revelation 13, it tells us that the
those who receive the mark of the beast
are going to receive the mark in their
forehead or in their hand. Revelation 73
and 14:1 tells us you can only receive
the seal of God in your forehead. The
forehead symbolizes what you believe.
The hand symbolizes what you do even if
you don't believe it. So, the hand is
signifying the actions that are not
necessarily in harmony with the belief.
That means these non-Christian nations
and even these secular individuals may
not believe in Sunday sacredness, but
they will go along with it for economic
reasons. They will receive the mark of
the beast in the hand instead of in the
forehead. And we see in recent history
how all of this could actually take
place in this prophecy could be
fulfilled.
>> Amen.
>> Good answer. Uh Johnny, your second
question. What does baptized for the
dead mean in 1 Corinthians 15:29?
This is from Diana.
>> Thank you, Diana. That's a very good
question. I was looking at this about 10
years ago and uh it's one of those
verses in the Bible that has really
created some confusion and uh many
different interpretations. In fact,
because of this verse, there's a group
of religious people that are actually
looking through genealogies and things
like that, trying to figure out who
their family members were, and they
actually are being baptized as a proxy
baptism for their dead relatives. Uh,
now, is that biblical? And let's take a
quick look at this. Uh, first I'm going
to read the verse that you mentioned.
Uh, otherwise, what will they do?
>> 1 Corinthians 15:29.
Otherwise, what will they do who are
baptized for the dead? If the dead do
not rise at all, why then are they
baptized for the dead? And so, what is
he talking about here? Is Paul talking
about something that was happening in
his day? Were Christians actually uh
being baptized for their dead relatives?
If you do a lot of reading on this, you
will find that there is no evidence that
the Christians were being baptized for
their dead relatives. And some have come
to the conclusion that Paul is talking
about that. But Paul is not talking
about that. He's talking about the
resurrection
of the dead. And so, uh, let's go ahead
and back up in 1 Corinthians 15. Let's
begin in verse 16. It says, "For if the
dead do not rise, then Christ is not
risen." The subject is the resurrection
of the dead. So verse 17, and if Christ
is not risen, your faith is futile. You
are still in your sins. Then also those
who have fallen asleep, those that have
died in Christ have perished.
If in this life only we have hope in
Christ, we are of all men the most
pitable. I like the King James version
that says most miserable. So verse 20,
but now Christ is risen from the dead
and has become the first fruits of those
who have fallen asleep. Paul is
clarifying, making it clear that Christ
did uh rise from the dead. For since by
man came death, by man that is Jesus,
also came the resurrection of the dead.
For as in Adam all die, even so in
Christ shall all or all shall be made
alive. It's talking about the res
resurrection of the dead. So why is 1
Corinthians 15:29 saying the way it's
written and I I would say that the way
it is written uh seems to say that there
are people being baptized for the dead.
But you have to look a little bit into
the Greek and you have to look at the
context in order to understand this. Uh
let's go to 1 Corinthians 15:29 again.
Otherwise, what will they do who are
baptized for the dead if the dead do not
rise at all? Let's stop there for a
moment. Paul is now talking that you
should be baptized for the dead. He's
not endorsing this. Uh in the Greek
word, there are different words that are
used for that word for which is the word
like cooper in Greek and it could mean
uh for or in view of or concerning.
And there are different words for this.
So I would say to you that here when it
says uh what would they do who are being
baptized in view of the dead uh you know
when somebody dies for example if there
are children they have departed from the
lord they're not following the lord in
funerals I have done it and I think
others have many others have done it as
well you know you know if you want to
see your parents again
you should consider following the
footsteps of your dead father your dead
mother because they were Christians and
you're not walking in the Christian way.
So concerning the dead, so if they make
a decision to follow Christ because of
the witness of their father or their
mother, then uh that is a reason to be
baptized for some people. Then you would
say then the next question, why then
they baptized for the dead if the dead
do not rise at all? So if you're being
baptized because oh my my father died
and I want to see him in the new
Jerusalem, but if they if there really
is no resurrection, why get baptized at
all? So Paul is making this argument in
order to establish that the dead do rise
and that we should consider this.
There's more I would share, but time is
over.
>> Amen. Amen. Very well said. Okay. Uh
let's see, Shelly, your second question.
James 1 says that we should pray without
doubting. But I've always thought we
should ask according to God's will. For
example, Jesus prayed in Gethsemane,
asking if the cup could pass from him,
yet submitted to God's will. Does James
1 mean that we we can expect God to
grant what we ask or are in our prayers
only meaningful if they align with his
will? How can I know if what I'm asking
is truly God's will? And this is from
Carol in Washington.
>> Carol, it's a thoughtful question and
it's one that many believers have
wrestled with in the past. James 16
says, "Ask in faith with no doubting."
It does not mean that we are demanding
God to give us exactly what we're asking
for, but rather that we trust his power
and his goodness to bring us our
request. Faith means not doub doubting
God's care. As our loving father,
sometimes God says yes, sometimes he
says wait, and sometimes he says no
because he knows the end from the
beginning. And everything he does is for
our eternal benefit. So we can pray with
confidence if we know his will is for
our eternal benefit. Jesus prayed his
prayer in Gethsemane as a perfect
example. He came boldly to the Lord and
was honest about his desire when he
said, "If it is possible, Father, let
this cup pass from me." But he went on
to say, "Yet not as I will, but your as
you will." That's Matthew 26:39.
So, it shows us it's good to ask boldly,
but also to trust God's higher wisdom.
So, how do we know if our prayers align
with his will? Scripture gives us
guidance. I'm going to give you just a
few reason things. One, know the
promises of God. If we pray for things
that God has promised, like forgiveness.
First John 1:9, that's a promise that he
will forgive us. If we're asking for the
Holy Spirit, Luke 11:13,
that's a promise that God is anxious to
give us his spirit. If we're asking for
strength to overcome sin, Galatians 5:16
tells us if we walk by the spirit, we
won't gratify the desires of our flesh.
If you're asking for wisdom, the Bible
says that James 15, he will give it to
you liberally.
Those are questions or prayers you ask.
You know God's going to answer yes. Now
in matters of daily life for your
health, your jobs or your relationships
or specific needs, what we do is pray
with faith and also with humility,
trusting that God sees the bigger
picture. He knows the end from the
beginning and he's only going to do
what's best for us. The second thing is
peace. We're counting on the promises.
Now, peace in his answers when we commit
our desires to him. Philippians 4:6 and
7 says that his peace will guard our
hearts and that peace is evident even
when the answer is different than the
one that we were expecting. We know that
God's will is good. James is encouraging
us not to waver between belief and
unbelief as if we doubt God's love or
his ability to ask. So faith means that
we trust that God hears, that he cares,
and that his answer, whether yes, wait,
or no, is always the best outcome for
us. Pray boldly, ask confidence. And
when prayer is in harmony with God's
will, he always answers yes. When you're
unsure, just choose, choose to trust him
and draw that he's going to draw you
closer to Jesus to prepare you for
eternity.
>> Amen.
>> Good word. Once again, I just want to
remind you uh how to get in touch with
us. If you want to text us, 6182283975.
If you'd like to email it, email your
questions in bibleqa3abn.tv
or if you'd like to use Instagram 3ABN
official.
Love these questions. Some of them are
mighty deep. Uh James, let's go to
question three.
The Bible says that we can't buy, sell,
or trade without the mark of the beast.
How will Christians get food during the
tribulation if the mark of the beast is
not physical? And this is from Chad.
>> Great question. You know, Christians who
refuse to compromise their worship of
God for the worship of earthly powers um
who are enforcing the Sunday laws and
the mark of the beast are going to have
to fully rely upon God for their food
and their water. And we need to rely
upon his promises. There's the words of
the hymn that I think about right now,
standing on the promises of God. So,
let's look at some of those promises.
Isaiah chapter 33:es
14- 16 says this concerning the time
ahead. The sinners in Zion are afraid.
Fearfulness has surprised the
hypocrites. And I just want to pause
there for a second. Zion is God's
church. There's going to be a great
shaking when the Sunday law comes. And
there's going to be fear and surprise
among the hypocrites and those who are
actually sinners even though they
profess to be followers of God. So who's
going to stand? Who's going to dwell in
this devouring fire? And that's talking
about this time of trial. A fire is
symbolic of trial. Who's going to stand?
Who's going to dwell in the everlasting
burnings? That's talking about actually
God's presence and the fact that those
who go through this trial are going to
be able to stand in God's presence. And
then the answer is given. He that walks
righteously, he that speaks uprightly,
he that despises the gain of oppressions
and shakes his hand from holding bribes,
he that stops his ears from hearing
blood and shuts his eyes from seeing
evil. And that of course is talking
about media and among other things, he
will dwell on high. The place of his
defense shall be diminitions of rocks.
And that's talking about the place where
God's people are going to flee in the
very end of time. Bread shall be given
him. his water shall be sure. This is
the promise of God's word relating to
the time of test that is going to be
brought to us when the mark of the beast
and Sunday laws are enforced. Jesus says
it this way in Matthew 4:4. He says,
"Man does not live by bread alone, but
by every word that proceeds out of the
mouth of God." And just a quick
reference here, this is from a book
called Adventist Home, page 141. I'm
going to reference you to another book
called Country Living. It says again and
again, the Lord has instructed that our
people are to take their families away
from the cities into the country where
they can raise their own provisions for
the in the future the problem of buying
and selling will be a serious one. So
our council right now is to get ready
for this time by being in the country
where we can raise our own food.
>> Thank you. Thank you, James. John, what
happens to a person's guardian angel
after they die? And this is from Linda
in Iowa.
>> That's a very interesting question,
Linda. I have to say I've never heard
this question before, but thank you for
sending it. Uh the Bible doesn't really
tell us what happens to the guardian
angels uh when the person dies. And you
know, this seems to be a a an
understanding that Christians have that
we all have a guardian angel. Uh and the
actual words guardian angels are not in
the the scriptures, but the concept is
there. So I want to share some
scripture. For example, Matthew 18:10,
Jesus is talking and he says, "Take heed
that you do not despise one of these
little ones, the children. For I say to
you that in heaven their angels always
see the face of my father who is in
heaven." So it lets us understand that
hey there are they have angels. We have
angels. And so uh Psalm 34:7 is another
scripture that you can consider. The
angel of the Lord encamps around those
who fear him and delivers them. So we
have the concept there that uh we have
uh guardian angels but what happens to
the angel when um when the person dies.
So the person is dead. Their job was to
watch over the uh that person. And so
some ask themselves, well, are they
there at the grave uh waiting for the
resurrection guarding? Uh we do not
know. Uh we we can look at the
scriptures and we see that angels seem
to have different jobs, different
positions, and different uh things
they're asked to do by God. So perhaps
this is where you start to think about
possibilities. Uh they are given another
task or perhaps they guard another
person. We do not know. Therefore, we
can't give you a complete thus sayeth
the Lord. We just know that uh they will
be busy. It's not okay. You're on
vacation now. You don't have to worry uh
until the resurrection of this
individual. Just take it easy. Go on a
vacation. Go see some of the planets. We
do not know. out there. But we do know
that God loves us so much that he is
willing to take care of his children and
the angels have that task. Imagine if
the Lord didn't have angels guarding us.
Uh what uh liberties would the devil
take? And so these angels are there to
protect us and to also uh hold back what
the devil would want to try to do to
God's children. So, we need to praise
the Lord for his mercy and for his
protection because uh of his great love
for us.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. That's a good answer not to have
an answer.
>> I mean there and there's uh there are
concerns and questions about certain
things. Uh Shellyley number three, why
was the book of Enoch taken out of the
Bible? This is from Don and Dana in
Wisconsin.
Don and Dana, I appreciate your question
and let me just say this and I don't I'm
saying this with respect. The book of
Enoch is an ancient Jewish writing and
it was actually never taken out of the
Bible because it was never included
as part of the inspired biblical cannon.
Let me give you three reasons why. One,
it's not inspired scripture. You know,
the Bible does quote um from other
writings. For example, Paul quoted some
of the pagan poets. Uh Jude 14 and 15
seems to refer to a saying that is found
in the book of Enoch. But that does not
mean that the book is an inspired
writing. The early church
decisions were made when the Jewish and
Christian leaders came together to
recognize and they did this prayerfully
to recognize what belonged in the Bible.
They looked for clear marks of
inspiration, consistency with the rest
of scripture because God does not
change. He's not capriccious and
acceptance of God's people of that book
over the time. And the book of Enoch did
not meet these standards. So, it was
preserved.
And and I'm, you know, it's interesting
that it was preserved because uh I mean,
there's there's good things to
understand Jewish history and thought
that makes it a valuable resource, but
it was not
canonical. In other words, it was not
included in the sacred books that were
officially accepted as Jew as genuine.
And actually, Enoch, the book of Enoch
has things that contradict scripture.
That's why it wasn't included in the
Older New Testament canon except in the
Ethiopian Orthodox Church which which
treats it as part of their tradition. As
Adventists, we believe that God has
preserved the scriptures that we need
for salvation. We see in 2 Timothy
3:15-17
that these were written by the Holy
Spirit or inspired by the Holy Spirit.
And the 66 books we have are complete
and they're trustworthy. They reveal
Christ and God's plan of redemption.
>> Amen. Thank you.
>> James number four. Please explain Romans
1 26-28.
And this is from Jackton.
>> Thank you Jack for that question. You
know the larger context of Romans 1 is
really Romans chapters 1-8. I mean the
whole book is good but Romans 1 through8
and the gospel in contrast with our
sinful nature. This is what Paul is
bringing out as he moves through Romans
chapter 1 verses 26- 28 of Romans 1
focus on one of the many sins that lead
us away from God. So Romans 1 is
teaching that God is the creator of all
based on the evidence that is all around
us in science and that even the sexual
and the mental and the spiritual
fallenness of our nature proves the
Bible to be true because God's word
actually warns us about our nature
telling us that our fallen nature will
prevail if we refuse to acknowledge and
receive God's grace and love which is
the gospel. So, Romans 1 tells us that a
God of love will eventually honor our
freedom and our choice and give us over
to those sins that we refuse to let go
of, including sexual sins like
homosexuality,
and will allow us to reap the
consequences. However, while some people
may want to focus on this one sin of
homosexuality, the context of Romans 1
lays out the fallenness of our nature as
inclusive of many sins, in fact, all
sins that we commit. And the Bible
reminds us in chapter 2 not to judge one
another since we're all sinners and
we're all saved only by God's grace. So
let's take a look at these verses. Uh
Romans chapter 1 and we'll begin with
verse 26. For this God caused God gave
them over to vile affections. For even
the women to change the natural use into
that which is against nature. And
likewise also men leaving the natural
use of the woman burned in their lust
one toward another. men with men,
working that which is unseemingly, and
receiving in themselves the recompense
of their error, which was meek. And even
as they did not like to retain God in
their knowledge, God gave them over to a
reprobate mind to do those things which
are not convenient, being filled with
unrighteousness, fornication,
wickedness, covetousness, maliciousness,
full of envy, murder, deceit, debate,
malignant, whisperers, backbiters,
haters of God, despiteful, proud,
boasters, inventors of evil things,
disobedient to parents, without
understanding, covenant breakers,
without natural affection, implacable,
unmerciful, who knowing the judgement of
God, that they which commit such things
are worthy of death, not only do the
same, but have pleasure in them that do
them. Therefore, chapter 2 verse one,
thou art inexcusable, oh man, whosoever
thou art that judgest another, for
wherein thou judgest another, thou
committest condemnest thyself. For thou
that judgest doeth the same things. So,
Romans 2 opens up by reminding us that
there's no room for judgment because
we're all sinners. Romans 3 confirms
that none of us are actually seeking
after God, not even one of us. Romans
3:9. And then Romans 3 thunders out the
gospel of God's justification through
the faith of Christ unto all and appall
all all them that believe. For there's
no difference since all have sinned and
come short of the glory of God.
>> Amen.
>> And it's our hope here at 3ABN that you
will say yes to Jesus Christ and his
lifechanging grace.
>> Thank you, James. Appreciate that. Good
answer. Uh Johnny, your fourth question.
Was Satan on earth before Adam was
created? And this is from John in Ohio.
Thank you, John. That's a good name, by
the way.
Um so the question is, was Satan on
earth before Adam was created? So let's
take a a a quick look at that and ask
ourselves concerning this because uh the
Bible says that God created the heavens
and the earth in six days and then
rested on the seventh day. So as we look
at creation and we say that the first
day God says let there be light and
there was light and then at the end of
that day God separates the light from
the darkness and that's the first day.
So is this when Satan is on the earth?
Well, no. Uh, it can't be because
there's really nothing. So, if we go
through each successive day, like for
example, the next day God creates the
firmament in the midst of the waters and
then separates the waters from above the
firm uh from above the firmament and
below the firmament. Second day is this
when the Satan is here. No. Uh the
answer that I uh recommend to you to
consider is that
Satan comes to earth after Adam and Eve
are created. That's after the sixth day.
And so the seventh day, that would be a
bad day. It's a rest day. So when did
when was the devil see now I please
understand that the devil could come and
visit? Uh because uh remember that when
a spirit is cast out, he goes through
dry places seeking rest. He's trying to
find a home base. He's trying to find a
place that he can call his own. And as
he sees the earth being created, he can
say, "Wow, that's a wonderful place to
live. I would like to live there." And
so, let's go to Revelation 12. In
Revelation 12, we go to verse 7, and it
says, "And war broke out in heaven.
Michael and his angels fought with the
dragon, and the dragon and his angels
fought." Now, please understand that
every word in the Bible is important.
Notice the wording. Verse eight. But
they did not prevail, nor was a place
found for them in heaven any longer.
Can't go back there and live. Maybe go
visit, but can't live there. Remember
that in Job chapter 1, it seems that
Satan came to visit, but he can't live
there. His place is no longer there. So
verse 9, so the great dragon was cast
out. That serpent of old called the
devil and Satan. Cast out where? When
you look in the Old Testament, it
doesn't say where he was cast out. It
just says cast out of the mountain of
God. But where? Now, before we answer
that, let's consider Jeremiah 29:1.
This is what God says to us. For I know
the thoughts that I think toward you,
says the Lord, thoughts of peace and not
of evil, to give you a future and a
hope. If we cling to the idea that the
devil as soon as he's cast out of heaven
and we consider this verse, God is not
giving us uh thoughts of peace and evil
if he cast the devil here to earth.
Please understand that the devil is cast
down to the earth after Adam and Eve
sin. Now he could come and visit before
that, but he can't stay here because
everything belongs to the Lord. And if
God has thoughts of peace and to give us
an ex a future and a hope, he's not
going to create the earth and then boom,
cast the devil down there. No, it's
after Adam and Eve sin that he can be
cast here to stay. That's his place. His
place uh his place of camp, his place
where it's his center for the war he
wants to create in this uh in this
universe. So let's go back to Revelation
12, keeping those things in mind. So
let's go to verse 9. So the great dragon
was cast out, that old serpent called
the devil and Satan. Notice he says who
deceives the whole world. Then it says
he was cast to the earth and his angels
were cast out with him. So this is the
scenario that we see in when we look at
the old testament cast out but nowhere
specifically in revelation 12 it says
that he was cast to the earth but it
says first that he deceives the world.
So when does he deceive the world? after
he tempts Adam and Eve and that's when
he can be cast to the earth as his home
base. So in
uh Ezekiel 28:16 it says by the
multitude concerning Lucifer by the
multitude of thy merchandise they have
filled the midst of thee with violence
and thou has sinned. Therefore, I will
cast thee out as profane out of the
mountain of God and then future and I
will destroy thee, oh covering cherub
from the midst of the stones of fire. So
in the Old Testament, he's just cast out
and then where am I going to live now? I
can't go back to heaven. That place can
is not mine. So it's after Adam and Eve
sin because he comes to tempt them. So
these are thoughts to consider.
>> Yes. Uh, is there anything that else
that we need to add that we've just
talked about here or otherwise we'll go
to a a a
break?
>> Well, if I may, we were talking about 1
Corinthians 15:29. Uh, the idea to get
baptized for somebody that's dead that
never accepted Christ is not biblical.
For example, we have in Acts 3:1 19,
Peter is talking. He says, "Repent
therefore and be converted that your
sins may be blotted out so that the
times of refreshing may come from the
presence of the Lord." So there's a need
for the individual to repent and be
converted and then be baptized. So if
you if you are getting baptized for
somebody that is dead, they cannot
repent. They cannot be converted. And
you're being baptized in their behalf is
really not biblical and of course is not
valid. And so, uh, I would say that it's
not something that should be done.
>> Amen.
>> And I just wanted to add really quickly
that there are, uh, when we were talking
about how do you witness to an atheist,
just get online and Google, there are
several Adventist writers who deal with
science, archaeology, and evidence for
God's existence. Clifford Goldstein,
Richard Davidson, John Ashton, Dr. Ariel
Roth of the GRRI, uh, Gearhard Huzzle
and Michael Huzzle who are
archaeologists and you can go to some
helpful resources. We have the BarRi,
the Biblical Research Institute that has
wonderful articles on this and the
Geoscience Research Institute, the GRRI,
which it's grda.org,
og. They have uh lots of studies
dedicated to origins, geology,
paleontology, biology, and faith.
>> Okay, we'll come back to that in just a
little bit, Shel. But let's do some
housekeeping right now. Let's take a
break, and we'll be right back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3AN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
6182283975.
That's 618-228-3975.
[Music]
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
>> Welcome back, guys, girls. Do we have
just one more thing that we might add to
this?
>> I am concerned about the people that
think that being baptized for the dead
is something that has value. It does
not. It's not biblical. And so, I want
to share from the scriptures Ezekiel
14:20. It says, "Even though Noah,
Daniel, and Job were in it, as I live,
says the Lord God, they would deliver
neither son nor daughter, they would
deliver only themselves by their
righteousness." Remember, the person has
to repent, be converted, and be baptized
in order for that to have value. And it
only has value for them.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah,
>> James,
>> totally agree. I really appreciate that,
Pastor John. Another verse that we can
add to it is Acts 2:38 where Peter says,
"Repent and be baptized." So, you have
to repent in order to be baptized.
>> Most certainly. Shelley, got a word?
>> You bet. You're worth nothing less than
the price that God paid to save you. And
that's with the blood of his own
precious son, Jesus Christ.
>> Amen.
>> Remember that.
>> Amen. And I just want to read this real
quickly in Proverbs 16:3. Commit to the
Lord whatever you do, and he will
establish your plans.
What a what a wonderful promise. So,
just know how much that we love you, we
respect you, and we look forward to
seeing you the next time. God bless.
>> Bye-bye.
Good morning.
[Music]